c'est un véhicule qui a été conçu pour
des missions de reconnaissance et qui
peine un canon justement pour pouvoir
appliquer des feux à longue distance
contre en ennemi
char ou un ennemi blindé léger
[Musique]
on a des emplacements peu de partout
dans dans le char les obus sont placés
un peu donc derrière le canon on a on en
a 12 entourés le 26 en caisse
je contrôle également tous les
paramètres qui vont venir influencer sur
le tir pour permettre à mon tireur de
faire de faire l'altitude de l'engin la
direction du vent pour l'extérieur la
température extérieure la température de
la poudre de la munition tout ça c'est
des paramètres qui peuvent influencer
sur le tir pour faire rater d'autres
objectifs on va disposer de 4 obus
différents on a le
BSCC c'est le bouli boulet simili charge
creuse qui lui va être seulement pour
les entraînements on a le l'obus charges
creuse
le bufflèche et l'obus explosif
[Musique]
je vais avoir ici ma lunette avec toutes
mes graduations à l'intérieur
pour pour savoir la distance de
l'objectif je vais avoir mon télémètre
mon télémètre laser tout ce qui va être
tir de nuit on a ici
la reproduction de la caméra thermique
avec ici le pupitre où je vais pouvoir
régler toute la qualité de la caméra
thermique et tout ce qui va avec
j'ai ici mon pupitre tireur pour faire
tous mes réglages
[Musique]
c'est un système de bande c'est avec
deux manettes donc pas pour tourner à
gauche on tire celle de gauche et on
pousse celle de droite ce qui fait que
les roues de gauche vont freiner et
l'euro de droite vont accélérer donc du
coup ça va permettre la rotation des du
char et un versement pour ton aide à
droite
[Musique]
avoir un engin qui a un tel rapport de
puissance et de taille c'est quand même
quelque chose d'assez rare dans les
armées
occidentales